we this is so [ __ ] weird we are
putting bacteria on our body just the
thought that I'm gonna be living a host
to other living things is a weird
thought for me I'm skeptical it's
magical basically and I'm really excited
about it I can't use deodorant oh you
throw to me I'll catch it this is the
mother dirt eh Oh missed it looks like
very intense the bacteria in this spray
is called ammonia oxidizing bacteria and
they consume irritating components in
sweat and convert them into beneficial
ingredients for the skin it says I'm to
expect a reduced dependency on soap
shampoo and deodorant as well as a more
hydrated balanced and less irritated
skin so there is a shampoo and there is
a cleanser that you could use in tandem
with this guessing I'm not super
optimistic but you know what they'll try
anything once apparently
today we are gonna put bacteria on me
for the first time didn't use deodorant
today we're scalp based armpits hands
package okay alright
sprayed my groin sprayed it I think
hopefully within a couple days I will
start working the end of day one and all
day I've been thinking oh like this is
working great it don't smell bad at all
but I just took my clothes off and smell
where fits and I feel really bad
what's wrong I don't smell good right
now is really good like detergent or
something I just woke up and usually
when I just wake up my skin is pretty
oily right now though it actually feels
pretty moisturized and the funny thing
is like it feels really smooth actually
isn't that bad once they get over the
mental gap of knowing that there's
millions of little creatures and now
call my body ho I just noticed that my
armpits are a different color the rest
of my body
they're like red and it kind of looks
like a rash I'm no longer using mother
dirt products and I actually feel like
they had a positive effect on my skin
yesterday I did get a compliment on my
skin and I was like oh is it the mother
dirt I don't know of my skin change I
think my skin pretty much stay the same
I'm not sure that my body reacted well
enough to the product to be able to
forgo deodorant I don't think I smelled
good I think anyone that was near me
when I stretched was pretty unhappy
about it yeah I'd say like the first
three days is pretty smelly and by the
end of the week and it adjusted and
everything was good I do not think I
could do this again it was just a little
bit too much for me to bear smelling the
way I did
granted Jen and Macy thought I smell
fine would I do this again maybe maybe
who knows we do all kinds of crazy we're
crazy kids
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half